it boils down to two questions
the first is is multiplying harder than
adding
so then the second question is why
and this is at the heart of what
complexity theory is it asks how
difficult are problems how how hard are
they
can you define what that means
and really how many steps does it take
to get to an answer
okay so i'm going to play a game with
you and the way this game works as
follows
as you can see i have a basket in front
of me and next to me i have
different types of fruits some of them i
might have multiple of
and what i'm going to do is in every
time step i'm going to either
pull out a fruit and then show it to you
and put it in the basket
or i'm going to reach in the basket and
pull a fruit out and show you what i
pulled out
and when i say query what i want you to
do is i want you to tell me
at least one type of fruit that's still
in the basket you don't have to know
everything that's in the basket but just
tell me one
so first i'm going to take a grapefruit
and put the grapefruit in the basket
then i'm going to take a pomegranate
and put that pomegranate in the basket a
pear
another pomegranate a plum
then i'm going to take a fruit out i'm
going to take a pomegranate out
and put in a grape and i'll take out
another pomegranate and put in a prickly
pear
a lime dragon fruit
pineapple and a cantaloupe
now i'm gonna take out a pear
a pineapple a prickly pear
cantaloupe dragon fruit
grape grapefruit
so query knife to tell me at least one
fruit
that's still in this basket okay good
queer
no not great sorry any any other guesses
i think you're randomly guessing right
oh but i haven't heard it and actually
there are actually two fruits that are
still in this basket
so so like it's not just one thing that
you
that works out here
what no
no okay so there's one plum left in one
line
one plum and one line so you may have
gotten the answer right and said either
plumber lime most of my
friends who i played this game with
weren't able to solve this problem
because provably
there is no deterministic method using
less memory than remembering everything
the deterministic method
is a method that doesn't make use of any
randomness a randomized method
would be one where i do use randomness
to guide my method okay and what do i
mean by that
the way you're going to choose what to
remember and what to forget is going to
be guided
by the outcomes of a random process so
you're going to say okay july now that
you put a papaya in
let me take these six coins they have on
the table and flip them each there are
two possibilities for the first coin two
for the second etc
so they're two to the six power number
of possibilities here there's 64
possibilities for these coins
and based on which of those 64 outcomes
happens
i'm going to use that to guide how to
choose what to remember and what not to
remember now that i've just put this
papaya in the basket so that's a
randomized approach
and it turns out that there in fact is a
randomized method for this fruit game
that does better than remembering
everything that does better than
deterministic methods
and what you can also prove
mathematically is that the best
randomized method we have for this fruit
game
is in fact the best method that's what
we call lower bounds
proving a lower bound on how much memory
you need
to be able to play this game and win
[Music]
so in the game with jalani we realized
that being randomized
can actually help us in
solving a problem which otherwise seems
hard
so this leads us to the notion of
studying
randomness as a resource now normally
when we think about computing
we say how much time is this computation
going to take
we ask how much memory we're going to
use but for mathematical reasons and the
reason that randomness is turning out to
be such a useful
mechanism to help us solve problems we
also now started
associating randomness as a fundamental
resource
along with time and memory
so suppose you find yourself in the
middle of a maze
and you want to get out one thing you
could try would be
a deterministic algorithm for getting
out of the maze
so for example you could try to remember
everywhere you've been as you're going
along through the maze
and at each junction you'd go to one of
the branches
that you've never been to before but in
order to execute this to get out of the
maze
you'd have to remember the entire maze
and every place you've been
which if the maze is big enough you
couldn't keep in your head so the
question is
can you get out of the maze without
remembering the entire portion of the
maze and where you've been
and it turns out with randomization with
random algorithms you can do exactly
that
the algorithm is extremely simple at
every time
you have a choice to make about where to
go you flip a coin
and you just go in the direction that
the coin suggests
we've known since the 1970s that
you'll not only explore new portions of
the maze but you'll actually get out of
the maze
in a reasonable amount of time after
that algorithm was was known it
was an open question in in computational
complexity
whether one could get out of the maze
deterministically by remembering very
little of the maze
and 25 years later such a method was
eventually shown a deterministic method
that remembered only
the equivalent of a few spots in the
maze
but the algorithm is extremely
complicated something that no human
would be able to do
much more complicated than this simple
randomized algorithm
and in fact it turns out to be slower
than the randomized algorithm at solving
the problem too
do
as researchers when we're trying to
solve a computational problem
we're essentially exploring a landscape
trying to find a path
to a specific location for example a
peak
we begin by using well-established
techniques following well-trodden paths
to try and reach their destination
[Music]
hmm
but there are lots of different paths
that we could take and some of those
paths lead to dead ends
when we're proving the lower bound we're
showing that it's impossible to
reach our destination with the tools in
hand
sometimes when we're trying to prove a
lower bound that is
trying to show that a particular path
leads to a dead end
instead we find that there is a hidden
path that we didn't know about
and that in fact can lead to a solution
that
is in fact innovative and surprising
[Music]
so
[Music]
so lower bounds would like to study
how much time let's say or any other
resource
are required to solve any given problem
so let's take a very simple example
we know when we try to multiply numbers
it's somehow a little harder as a task
than when we try to add numbers i can
add 10 digit numbers in my head and give
you the answer
i cannot multiply to 10 digit numbers in
my head and give you the answer
we would like to convert this belief
that we have about the inherent
complexity
the hardness of this problem into a
lower bound saying
oh every algorithm that multiplies two
numbers which are both
n digits long will take much more than n
amounts of time
and the natural algorithm that we can
think of actually takes n square steps
we write down
the product of the first digit
multiplied with the number
and then the second digit multiplied by
the number and so on we write lots of
numbers together
roughly two n digit numbers we will
write n squared intermediate digits
before we
start producing the answer now we might
want to say that this
n squared is the right lower bound
unfortunately this is false
and this is one of the fundamental
challenges in dealing with algorithms
the first algorithm that you deal with
that you come up with for solving a
problem might not be the best
in the case of multiplication this
algorithm that we have known from our
elementary school days is not the best
there is much faster algorithms out
there they do not run in time n squared
their running time is really much much
much closer to the time it takes to add
to n
digit numbers but it is still somewhat
larger
so one challenge in dealing with
algorithms
is that they can be very devious they
can be very tricky they can be very
clever
and we have to deal not with the first
algorithm that we think about but
all the algorithms in the world proving
lower bounds against them
is turning out to be very challenging
and we are very
much in our infancy for instance to this
date
we do not know that multiplication is a
harder problem
in this sense than addition
so there are deep connections between
lower bounds and upper bounds
oftentimes you can say they're kind of
two sides of the same coin
but lower bounds are what interest me
most
they talk about impossibility that
something really needs a certain amount
of time before you can know the answer
and this isn't just about incremental
speed ups or
whether you can optimize here just get a
tiny bit faster there
to me these are talking about
qualitative differences
if you can say a problem takes an
exponential number of steps before you
reach the answer
you can say something like you won't
know the answer until the sun engulfs
the earth
complexity three lower bounds really
talks about
what is knowable within our lifetimes
computation and computational processes
underlie everything that's going on in
nature in biology
and in physics at the lowest level there
are computations
going on and there are fundamental laws
about how these
operate their limits to what is possible
for
computations to do and so the study of
lower bounds and computational
complexity
like many other things in mathematics is
really about
the fundamental laws of the universe
[Music]